[Música]
Hola a todos me llamo Valle soy
senegalés vivo en la región de Dakar en
que urmazar en este vídeo voy a
mostrarles cómo nuestros dirigentes han
destruido la costa norte de la cara
nuestro observador by One estudia
medicina y también es youtuber
normalmente en sus vídeos habla de
celulares pero dice que después de haber
visto nuestro programa decidió realizar
un vídeo sobre un tema totalmente
diferente el estado de las playas cerca
de su casa y más en general en las
afueras de Dakar se hace mal duele ver
que el lugar donde pasamos nuestros días
está cada vez peor y que no hay nada que
podamos hacer al respecto esto se
extiende a lo largo de 17 kilómetros
desde tihuahua nepeul hasta diamalaya
conté al menos 9 entradas de aguas
residuales que desembocan directamente
en la playa empezamos en tibauano donde
empieza la carretera bdn3 hay una planta
de tratamiento de aguas residuales
escondida detrás de los Pinos
australianos en las imágenes los
satelitales de años anteriores había
visto que salía agua de esta planta lo
que no me pareció normal y Para mi
sorpresa Ayer cuando vi las imágenes
satelitales Vi que había un nuevo
desagüe justo al lado de la planta de
tratamiento Qué paradoja aún así fui a
echar un vistazo en la parte de atrás de
la planta hay un tubo que sale de la
pared y que Descarga las aguas
residuales directamente en la playa a
nuestro observador le preocupa que el
rápido crecimiento urbano de Dakar tenga
repercusiones en las playas donde creció
en los años 40 a lo largo del litoral se
plantó una franja de pinos australianos
para proteger las costas de la erosión
era una gran franja de pinos
australianos estaba lleno de árboles
como un bosque como un bosque pero en
2021 el gobierno senegalés anunció que
ya no protegería 150 hectáreas de pinos
australianos en los alrededores de Dakar
esto con el objetivo de facilitar la
construcción a las autoridades locales
arrasaron con todo ahora es un desierto
con casas opción esto es el barrio
gadaya quien quiere Aguayo y es también
el lugar donde más se materializa la
masacre de los Pinos una enorme
superficie con cientos de tubos para
preparar una Urbanización anárquica
además en la playa se vierte un gran
caudal de agua
seguimos Nuestro camino y esta vez nos
detenemos unos metros antes de la playa
de Malibú también en hueyagualle aquí
fluye un enorme caudal de agua que
ensucia esta hermosa playa
desde la playa de Malibú si uno Mira
hacia el puente de carberene puede ver
otro desagüe 600 metros más allá también
hay que tener en cuenta que el día que
grabé Este vídeo era a la 1 pm a esa
hora no hay casi nadie pero a las 5 de
la tarde muchísima gente viene a estas
playas muchas personas están a veces en
contacto directo con estas aguas por lo
que no es solo un problema
medioambiental sino también un enorme
problema de salud pública hace 10 años
si uno mira las imágenes satelitales De
esta zona solo había cinco tubos que
desembocaban en el mar Hoy hay 19 19 son
demasiados baile nos dijo que espera que
su vídeo desde que hablar y que planea
grabar más
este esqueleto dinosaurio fue
descubierto en 2018 durante una
expedición paleontológica entre Estados
Unidos y Nigeria en la región de agadez
en el sael nigeriano este tipo de
descubrimiento es poco común los
saurópodos son uno de los animales más
grandes que ha habitado el planeta
además su esqueleto estaba casi intacto
en noviembre de 2022 un equipo dirigido
por el paleontólogo estadounidense Paul
sereno acudió al lugar para exhumar al
saurópodo una vez allí descubrieron algo
aún más sorprendente
vincentrenó un paleontólogo voluntario
que participó en esta Aventura nos
cuenta de qué se trata Este año cuando
llegamos al lugar estaba el dinosaurio
que habían encontrado en 2018 pero
cuando Buscamos un poco más encontramos
otros esqueletos de hecho sacamos cinco
saurópodos Estos son grandes dinosaurios
con un cuello largo una cola larga los
animales terrestres más grandes que han
existido por lo que el trabajo de
extracción fue enorme a menudo nos
preguntan si podríamos ver dentro de la
tierra con un radar o algo así etcétera
no no funciona así no tenemos la
tecnología para saber lo que hay en la
Tierra la única forma de averiguarlo es
excavando a menudo lo comparo con
recoger setas con un poco de práctica
los paleontólogos pueden diferenciar los
huesos de las piedras clásicas en el
video de hecho agarro algunos huesos con
la mano para acercarlos un poco más a mi
teléfono
y ahí se puede ver una estructura porosa
en el interior Esas son las estructuras
típicas que hay dentro de todos los
huesos ya sea de un humano o de
dinosaurio
se estima que los saurópodos vivieron en
la tierra entre hace 145 y 180 millones
de años su exhumación debe realizarse
con sumo cuidado por eso para
desenterrarlos sin dañarlos los
paleontólogos los enyesan y después los
cortan en secciones utilizamos todos los
medios a nuestra disposición puede ser
un pico o una pala un martillo un
martillo neumático cavamos alrededor del
esqueleto de modo que solo nos quede Por
así decirlo una isla con el dinosaurio
que sobresale de la tierra y ya se sobre
un gran Terrón de sedimentos lo cortamos
en grandes secciones lo que nos permitió
por ejemplo en este caso sacarlo en
cuatro o cinco grandes placas de yeso y
no en una sola los huesos van a viajar
un poco van a salir pronto de níger
porque Lamentablemente
dispone de Laboratorios de paleontología
capaces de encargarse de la preparación
de estos huesos van a pasar unos años en
Estados Unidos porque es un proceso
largo allá preparadores profesionales
con experiencia y bien equipados podrán
encargarse de estos huesos y una vez que
todo esto se haya hecho podremos
estudiarlos el trabajo de los
paleontólogos consiste en comprender
cómo funcionaban los medio ambiente en
el pasado para poder entender mejor cómo
funcionan ahora
de esta manera llegamos al final de los
observadores por esta semana Si desea
enviarnos imágenes relacionadas con la
actualidad que haya tomado visto
circular todos nuestros contactos están
en nuestra pantalla en nuestro sitio web
observers France 24.com Hasta pronto